hi
i'm justin mahood i'm a product manager
on cloud run for anthos
and i'm adam kane i'm an engineering
manager on cloud run for anthos
and we're here today to show you how to
build a scalable web application using
cloud run for anthos on gke
so first i'll give you an overview of
cloud run for anthos
which is the technology that's at the
core of the sample that we want to show
you today
then we'll talk through some of the
problems that you'll need to solve
when standing up an enterprise web
application in a kubernetes environment
and then we'll walk through our sample
architecture and talk about the
different tools
in the anthos and gke ecosystem that
you'll use to deliver this kind of
application and then finally i'll give
you a short demo
of how to deploy our sample directly
into your gcp environment
so let's introduce you to the product
that's at the core of this sample
cloud run for anthos
when developing web applications
serverless patterns are very very
popular
and why is that well there's the
operational model you don't have to
worry about infrastructure
it's inherently scalable and you pay for
what you use
but for developers it's really the
programming model that's attractive
they also don't have to worry about the
infrastructure management and
fundamentally it's optimized for service
based architectures
like web applications but at the same
time we've got kubernetes
which is now the deep facto platform for
running containers
in the enterprise and the the de facto
enterprise operations platform
in general so
what if we could have the benefits of a
serverless development platform
with all of the control and flexibility
of kubernetes
and that's exactly why we created cloud
run for anthos
you can also think of cloud run for
anthos as kubernetes the easy way
developers get that serverless
experience where they can focus on their
application and their application
logic rather than worrying about the
intricacies of kubernetes deployments
and all of the
kubernetes concepts that go along with
it
so you can say that cloudrun for anthos
gives you the best of both worlds
gives you the best of serverless you can
run any standard docker container
uh it has request based auto scaling
it's very fast and scales down to zero
includes incremental rollouts and
rollbacks so you can do things like blue
green deployments and roll back from
and it also has a whole suite of
monitoring and logging tools that are
built in for the developer out of the
box
and at the same time the operations team
gets all the benefits of
kubernetes environment the flexibility
and control that comes with gke
integrated policy support the ability to
run your compute completely within a vpc
custom node types and customization of
the underlying hardware
and the extensive toolset that the
kubernetes ecosystem provides
and i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
that cloud run for anthos is based on
the k-native open source project
this is an open source project that was
started by google with contributions
from over 80 companies
and really what this guarantees is that
the workloads that you write and
architect for cloud run for anthos
are portable between k-native
environments in whichever cloud platform
you ultimately end up choosing
so now let's talk about actually
building an architecting web application
so let's imagine for a moment
you're a developer in an e-commerce
company
gke in kubernetes is the ops platform
that your company has chosen and
standardized
and you're given a task with delivering
a line of business web application for
tracking your warehouse inventory on a
pretty tight timeline
so it's monday morning you sit down with
your cup of coffee you sharpen your
pencil
and you start sketching out the
architecture that you're going to use
and this is sort of what's in your head
to begin with you know that it's going
to run in gcp
you know that there's going to be a web
application of some kind and you know
that
it ultimately needs to run on both
desktop laptop and mobile devices
but then you really start to break it
down you know you're going to need a
front end
you're going to you're going to need a
back end and a database to store your
state
you start breaking it down some more and
and some more requirements really start
to come into view
since your company is standardized on
gke you're going to use cloud run for
amthos for your back end services
for all the serverless benefits in the
kubernetes platform we talked about
earlier
and also you know you're going to need
to access and modify
data in a database in a secure fashion
so in addition to using firestore as a
database
you want to be able to use your
kubernetes service identities for this
authentication
and you'd be remiss if you hadn't
thought a little bit about how load
balancing
and your urls were going to work and you
realized because you want to serve your
front end from a status storage bucket
but have your back end services running
in cloud run for anthos you need the app
to be on a single endpoint and subdomain
for coors reasons and you need
path-based routing between the front-end
served from gcs and your multiple
back-end services running on cloud run
for anthos
and also your enterprise has a hardcore
requirement that everything needs to be
https out of the box
as it should be and that your gke
cluster can't be connected to the
internet
and finally as the last requirements
start to come into view
you realize that you need to make sure
this web application is accessible only
by employees they absolutely have to
authenticate
and they need to use your company's
federated identity provider
also there's different role-based
features for workers
and managers of the warehouse so you
need to have role-based access and an
authorization platform for each call
that goes through
you're going to use istio for that
so after a couple of weeks of hard work
of architecting and writing the
application
you're ready to hand it off and start
managing inventory in your warehouse
using an application you designed to run
on cloud run for anthos
but you sort of thought to yourself it
should be great if there was a blueprint
for all of this
and it turns out that there is the cloud
run for anthos reference web application
you can see the link it's hosted up
there on github today and it's an
opinionated set of best practices aimed
at
demonstrating a reference architecture
for building an enterprise-grade web
application on gcp
using cloudrent for anthos so now i'm
going to kick it over to my friend adam
and he's going to take you through each
of the
components of the architecture that we
talked about a little bit earlier
and go into a deep dive about how we
implement those and how you can
implement them in your environment
adam thank you justin
as justin mentioned i'm going to walk
you through a little bit of a deeper
look
at some of the decisions that we've made
in implementing our
reference web application
so we'll start with a quick overview of
the reference architecture
that we've used the goal of our
reference application is to simulate
a line of business web application
that's built around the cloud run for
anthos platform
the subject matter of our application in
this case is inventory management
but this is mostly arbitrary the goal of
this application is to provide
a reference for implementing common web
application patterns
using cloudrin for anthos in combination
with other gcp services
in this case we've implemented the
application using angular
and go but the infrastructure patterns
that we demonstrate here are not
specific to these languages
so as a quick overview of the
architecture
it's comprised of a front-end ui and
multiple back-end
stateless services it's exposed through
a google cloud load balancer which
provides a consolidated endpoint to our
end user
the front-end ui is statically served
from a gcs bucket
and our back-end services are hosted
using cloudrun for ampos
end user authentication and
authorization of our backend api
requests are handled by istio
in combination with the google identity
platform and our application state
is stored in a firestore database
let's now take a look in a little bit
more detail about each of the three
major infrastructure patterns that we've
used in a reference application
first we'll talk about the database that
stores state for
our application of course our backend
services
need to be able to access and modify the
data
in this database in a secure fashion
ideally we should be able to
access this database using the service
identities for our backend services
and not have to manage explicit secrets
or other authentication tokens we use
firestore in this case which is
compatible with gcp
im authentication but this discussion is
really relevant
to any database or service which
provides authentication using iam
our backend services because they're
running on cloud run for anthous are
bound to kubernetes service accounts or
ksas
we use a feature of gke called workload
identities
to bind these kubernetes service
accounts to google service accounts or
gsas
in iam once this binding is in place
we can apply our access permissions for
our database to the google service
accounts
and through workload identity these
permissions apply transitively to our
kubernetes service accounts
once we've enabled workload identities
on our cloud road
for anthos cluster binding service
accounts
is a two-step process that requires
action in both
gke and iam in gke
each kubernetes service account is
annotated with the gcp service account
annotation
which specifies the google service
account that we are binding the
kubernetes
service account to
in iem a policy binding is created
against the google service account and
this policy binding specifies the
kubernetes service account and the name
space that that google service account
will be bound to
if you're paying close attention here
you'll notice that
we don't specify a specific gke cluster
with this policy binding this is because
workload identity bindings apply to all
kubernetes service accounts
which reside in a matching namespace
across all clusters in the target
project
this is an important detail to consider
when you're thinking about how to manage
your gcp resources in your project
structure
but keep in mind that the binding will
only take effect if the kubernetes
service count
is also annotated as described here
next we're going to look a little bit
about into how
we uh have solved load balancing and
request routing
so just a quick reminder about our
requirements in this case
we want to have a single endpoint and a
single sub domain
for our application we need path-based
routing to route requests between our
front-end and our back-end service
our end-user traffic should be secured
with https
and to avoid exposing our cluster
ingress to the internet we would like to
restrict access to cluster ingress if
possible
it would also be very nice if we could
use kubernetes resources to manage
all of our load balancing infrastructure
for the application let's see
in a little bit more detail how we've
addressed these requirements in our
reference web app
in this diagram you can see the resource
layout for the load balancer used in our
reference
web application if you're not familiar
with gclb this diagram probably looks a
little bit intimidating
but we'll break it down over the next
few slides and look at each section in
more detail
at the heart of our load balancer is
what's known as a url map
and our url map defines an association
between request paths
and backend resources in this case our
url map includes a default route to a
backend bucket
associated with the gcs bucket that
contains our static application assets
it also includes path specific routes to
multiple backend services
which are each mapped to individual
cloud run for antho services running on
our cluster
by default a custom host header is
required to ensure that requests
received by the cluster ingress
are sent along to the correct service on
our cluster
in this case we're using gclb to inject
these host header values
and to make sure that our requests are
sent to the appropriate service on the
cluster
in the case of the reference application
we've configured our load balancer to
terminate ssl
we've used a google managed ssl
certificate for you
for this case
because our end user traffic always
starts at the gclb endpoint
our cluster ingress doesn't need to be
exposed directly to the internet
traffic to the ingress of the cluster
can be restricted to only be allowed
from
trusted sources such as gclb's
well-known ingress ranges
this can be achieved through either
using a private cluster
or as in the case with our reference
application using firewalls to restrict
where that traffic can originate from
when you provision our reference web
application with the automation we've
included in github
we'll actually automatically apply these
ingress traffic rules
to restrict access to the cluster
there's a lot of individual resources to
provision
and manage with a load balancer like
this
the config connector or kcc provides the
ability to manage all of these resources
using krm and they do this by defining
kubernetes crds for each of these gcp
resources
in the case of our reference application
we install kcc
on the same cluster used to host our
backend services
infrastructure for our application can
then be provisioned and managed
by creating kcc resources on the same
cluster
you can reference and reuse any of the
infrastructure configuration that we
talk about in this presentation
by referencing the krm in our github
repository
you can connect cloudrun for anthos to a
gclb load balancer
using a standalone network endpoint
group or an neg
cloudrun for anthos uses istio to manage
its request ingress to the cluster even
when you don't explicitly install istio
we package a minimal version of it with
cloudrun for anthos when you're
installed on the cluster
all requests that are bound for user
services on your cloud run for anthos
cluster
first arrive at what's called the istio
ingress gateway service
on the cluster and are then routed from
there to the appropriate user service
to connect to gclb we are going to
create a network endpoint group
associated with the ingress gateway on
our cluster
to do this we add a cloud.google.com
neg annotation to the istio ingress
gateway service resource and this is
just a standard
kubernetes service resource in response
gke will add the neg status annotation
automatically to that service resource
and this annotation will include the id
and the zone of the associated network
endpoint group
we'll now create a backend service to
associate with this network endpoint
group
we want to bind our gclv backend service
to a specific end user service on the
cluster
so we configure the backend service with
a
custom request header for the host
header field
of the request cloudrun for anthos
uses this host header value to determine
where to route the requests once they
arrive at the istio ingress gateway
service
all of the requests as a result
forwarded to this backend service
will arrive at our desired
user service on the cluster
the network endpoint group is then added
as a back end
to this backend service using its id and
zone that we received from the gke
annotation in this case the backend
service is associated with
foo.example.com and we can now include
this backend service in the url map of
our load balancer so that we can route
requests to it
in the examples on the slide we've
showed gcloud commands
to provision these resources but it's
also possible to
provision these resources using config
connector you can see an example of this
if you look at the krm resources in our
github repository
finally we're going to cover how we
handle end user authentication
and authorization for the reference
application
as a refresher we're building an
application here for internal use by
employees so it's important that we
authenticate
each end user that arrives at our
application
we would like to use a federated
identity provider
and we'd also like to implement email
and password authentication
as well we're going to need role-based
authorization to allow us to limit
access to certain features
on the application based on a custom
user role
assigned to each user in this case users
can be either workers
or managers
let's take a look at how we've solved
authorization and authentication on
our reference application so we've
chosen to use google as our federated
identity provider this allows end users
to sign into the application with their
google account
we've also implemented email and
password authentication
however this is mostly to easily enable
certain testing scenarios
covering how this works and to end
when a user authenticates with our
application
they receive a json web token
and this json web token is used by the
front end
uh to make api calls to our backend
services
when a request arrives at the istio
ingress gateway
istio is configured to validate these
tokens with the gcp identity platform
and also enforce role based role-based
authorization
for various methods and apis on our
backend services
here you can see an example of the istio
authentication policy created to
validate these json web tokens
against the google identity platform in
this case it applies to all requests
with paths that begin with the slash
api prefix
we also configure authorization in this
case with istio resources and you can
see an example of that here
in this case this policy authorizes
access to the post method of the
inventory transaction api
for end users with the role type worker
all of the authentication and
authorization resources used in a
reference application can be found in
our github repository
i'm now going to hand it over to justin
for a demo of how
to provision the reference web
application in your gcp project
now i'm going to give you a quick demo
of how easy it is to get the sample up
running and deployed into your gcp
project directly from github as you can
see here i am
on the github repository for the sample
application
and here is the readme and this readme
actually has a step-by-step walkthrough
and includes scripts that will get the
sample built and deployed into your
cluster which i'm going to show you a
little bit of right here
you can see there's a big blue button
that says open in google cloud shell
what this actually does is it clones
this repository into
in your gcp cloud shell vm and from here
you can edit the code and then follow
along with the readme to deploy it
right into your gcp environment um so
i've already got this set up ahead of
time but what i am going to do
uh is go ahead and run the included
script to kick off cloud build
and get the application deployed into my
environment
i'm gonna kick off a make
and as you can see it's getting started
there and i'm going to hop over here to
cloud build and you'll see that that has
triggered a cloud build
it should be running now um you can see
that that build is running
uh from what i kicked off in cloud shell
there and it's it's fetching the source
from the
uh latest commit
now given this is going to take a little
bit of time to set up
go through all these steps and set up
the infrastructure i'm going to skip
ahead in time
to a build that already completed and
show you that i've got the back end
services for the application running in
cloud run for anthos
and you can see there's a user service
and a back end service
for different components of the api that
the application is calling
um and uh over the last hour you can see
some
metrics hasn't been a whole lot of
utilization because i just spun this up
but you can see the request count the
number of containers instances for the
back end etc
and then finally i can actually just
show you the application
running live here i can click
the g button to log in
now i've logged in it's going to load
the inventory of items
there we go perfect
so to sum everything up cloudrun for
anthos gives you the best of serverless
development patterns
in a kubernetes environment by
integrating
with the suite of other gcp services
it's possible to implement an
enterprise-ready web application
using cloud run for anthos and the rest
of the anthos and gke ecosystem
and finally everything we just showed
you is open source and available on
github
for you to try and deploy into your own
gcp environment
so on behalf of adam and everyone here
at google cloud
we want to thank you for watching our
presentation and hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day